[Music]
this episode is sponsored by fabulous
the number one self-care app that helps
you start building better habits the
first 100 people who click on the link
in the description will get 25 off a
fabulous subscription
[Music]
the little ciliate you see swimming
through the field of debris on your
screen right now has a fun name it's
called rhino thrix porculus
the first part of that name rhinothrix
combines the greek words rhino for nose
and thricks for hair
no the name is not an ode to nose hair
rather the name is a reference to the
hair-like cilia around the organism and
the fact that up there at one end is
what looks like a teeny tiny nose
the second part of the organism's name
porculus translates to pig and that
makes sense because rhino thrick's
porculus likes to live in mud
this little organism belongs to the
family spathididae though we're just
going to call them by their common name
spathidids
spathitids are found in freshwater and
marine habitats but they're also often
found in soil and some time ago james
our master of microscopes received 60
soil samples from a far away forest on
the eastern edge of poland storing them
in plastic bottles in his bathroom and
every so often like a force of nature
gathering over a woodland james adds
water to those samples and watches the
organisms go wild
and wild they go this is a recording of
one of their feeding frenzies which we
think involves a horde of spathitids
wreaking havoc on a population of
ciliates called culpadids
it is chaos in microbial form and if
you're having trouble making out exactly
what's going on don't worry that's kind
of the specific experience for you
the family spathitaday is made up of
around 20 genera which encompasses
around 250 known species and there's a
lot of variety in this befitted family
to sort through for example the largest
species is about 35 times larger than
the smallest and as far as shape goes
well their name is a callback to the
origin of the word spatula and you can
see that spatula shape in some of the
species when the broadness of its front
end comes into view but that is not
universal some species are more round
others more cylindrical and others take
on shapes that require words like
bachelor form and a lunate and turbinate
to describe them and all spathitids are
fairly flexible which helps them bend
and wiggle around whatever obstacle the
microcosmos throws their way they can
glide along mud particles but in water
they can also swim by spinning around
some specides though put their
flexibility to work in other forms of
movement like this species ducking in
and out of the substrate in motions that
look more like a worm than the spinning
ciliate we saw earlier
as diverse as spathitids are there are a
few helpful features they all have in
common one is that large circle you see
on the back of their body
that is the contractile vacuole which
helps control the amount of fluid inside
the organism as they swim through the
water the spathitids accumulate water
and other fluid in their bodies and
while water is you know essential if
there's too much the spathit will burst
so to avoid that watery explosion they
rely on those large contractile vacuoles
to gather excess fluid and then expel it
back out into the world so in a way what
you are looking at is the specific
equivalent of a bladder taking up a
large amount of space so that the
ciliate can do its own version of peeing
spathits are colorless but as you can
see here they sometimes take on a green
coloring that's not their own pigments
though they take on the verdant hue
thanks to algae that have either taken
up residence as a symbiont or that have
had the misfortune to be eaten
in some cases like with our rhino
thricks from earlier you can also see
bright shimmering lights glowing from
within
some of those are crystalline parts of
the organism while others are sugars
that refract beautifully under our
microscope's light to hunt down their
food spathits rely on the toxicists
lining their mouths to immobilize their
prey and from there some species will
swallow their meals whole while others
will use chemicals released by their
toxicits to mash their meals up outside
their body like a little protist
smoothie that they can just slurp up
now for all the distinctive traits of
these different species they are quite
difficult to identify just by looking at
them under a microscope many of the
traits that differentiate them are
subtle rooted in features that don't
immediately reveal themselves to us
instead scientists have to turn to other
methods to bring those traits to light
take this species for example which
we're pretty sure belongs to the genus
protospithidium
one way for us to know for sure though
is to look for a specific part unique to
the genus but we cannot see it without
killing the organisms and adding stains
that highlight that part
so that's why so much of our specified
footage is
vaguely labeled it's hard to figure out
exactly what they are without killing
them and we don't really want to do that
that doesn't mean though that we can't
enjoy watching them digging through
their lives
and there are a few species that we have
been able to identify a bit further like
this moving ball of fuzz which james is
pretty sure belongs to the genus
penardiella in fact it might even be
completely new
when james first saw it under the
microscope he thought it must be a
damaged cell but he was shocked when he
started to find many more like it on his
slide so now he's collecting more data
to see whether or not this really is
a new species
[Music]
for comparison this is another member of
the penardiela genus that we think is
penardiella on gelata if we are correct
about this this would be the first time
someone has documented this species in
almost 90 years
species belongs to the genus perispira
but there's not much known about it
except that its mouth spirals around its
body which is definitely a helpful trait
when it comes to identifying the species
and james is doing some more molecular
work with this species to see if he can
unravel more of its mysteries
but until then the spathetids remain
just about as murky and opaque as the
mud they come from though perhaps just a
little bit more beautiful to look at
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
we're going to be taking the next couple
of weeks off from uploading so we can
catch up on some stuff but we will be
back on march 28th with a brand new
episode before we go though we want to
say thank you to fabulous for sponsoring
this episode
fabulous is an app created by behavioral
science researchers to gently support
your personal goals
habit changing and habit building
is hard so if you're looking for ways to
add a new thing to your routine fabulous
is the way to go
their journey feature makes it easy to
set goals and track your progress using
the roadmap with over 20 million users
fabulous can help you whether you're
looking for ways to stay focused at work
need a reminder to take a break once in
a while to stretch and drink some water
or if you're looking to develop a whole
new post-work routine the app is 100
personalized two-year goals and with
their daily coaching and goal setting
you can start building your ideal daily
routine the first hundred people who
click on the link in the description
will get 25 off a fabulous subscription
[Music]
we also of course need to say thank you
to all of the names that are on the
screen right now these are a bunch of
human beings who wiggled out of the mud
one day and decided they wanted to see
some very peculiar kinds of content on
youtube.com
that content is the thing you're
watching right now journey to the
microcosmos and these are our patrons
and i'm sorry that i said that they
wiggled out of the mud though i don't
think that they'd mind if you want to
become one of our patrons on patreon or
maybe you're thinking you might you can
go to patreon.com
journey2micro we really appreciate
everybody who supports the channel if
you want to see more from our master of
microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram and if you want
to see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you